many data science concepts build on
previous work with relational databases
companies have been capturing and
analyzing data for decades
even today the relational database
management system is the cornerstone of
enterprise data
you need to understand the dbms terms on
your data science projects
one place you'll likely run into them is
when you're focused on data warehouses
an enterprise data warehouse or edw is a
special type of relational database that
focuses on analyzing data
traditional databases are optimized for
online transaction processing or oltp
a data warehouse is used for analytical
processing or olap
think of it this way the typical
database is focused on working with data
in real time
a data warehouse is focused on analyzing
what already happened
imagine you have a website that sells
running shoes
you've hired an engineer to create your
database
they've created dozens of different
tables and relationships
there's a table for customer address a
table for shoes
a table for shipping options and so on
your web server would use a sql
statement to search the data
when a customer buys a shoe it would
join their shipping address to the shoe
then it would give them their shipping
options
you'd want this database to be fast and
efficient
it's a transactional oltp database
it should be optimized so that when a
customer finds their shoe
joins it to their address and ships it
to their house you want your database to
focus
on speedy returns your customer wants to
do this in real time
you may ask your database engineer to
create a script that uploads the data
each day to your warehouse
your data warehouse is optimized for
analytical processing
it's an olap database focused on
creating reports
you might have a data analyst create a
report to see if there's any connection
between a customer's address
and the types of shoes they buy you
might find that people in warmer areas
are more likely to buy brightly colored
shoes than you take this information and
update the way your website presents the
data
you can change your website so that
customers from warmer climates see
lighter shoes at the top of the page
now say that your website has been very
successful
it was bought by a company that sells
sports clothing
that company has one warehouse for all
their websites
they want to take the data from your
website and combine it with all their
other websites
the company will do something called etl
which stands for extract
transform and load they'll pull the data
from all their websites
then they'll load the data into their
enterprise data warehouse
the company will extract the data from
your website in a standard format then
they'll transform the data into
something that works well with their
data warehouse
their warehouse could have a different
schema than yours the data analyst will
spend most their time scrubbing and
joining the data so it will fit
finally they'll load the transformed
data into the data warehouse
a typical data science team will have
similar challenges
they'll also very likely use the same
language
one thing you might hear is we need to
etl the data in the warehouse
so we can move it into the hadoop
cluster what this means is that the data
analysts need to transform your data so
they can move it into your cluster
another area where this may come up is
that many organizations see hadoop as a
replacement for data warehouses
you see a lot of companies rewriting
their etls so they can load data into a
hadoop cluster than they phase out or
shut down their warehouse
organizations that are hoping to save
money by storing data on inexpensive
hardware
data warehouses are usually a costly
appliance
in either case you'll certainly run into
these terms and concepts as part of your
data science team
try not to get overwhelmed by the
language
unfortunately much of data science is
still about gathering the data
you'll spend many hours in etl meetings
before you can ask any interesting
questions
if you understand the terms and
challenges then you're more likely to
get the data that you need